monsieur Darmanin est un petit ministre
de l'Intérieur qui au vu de son bilan
pitoyable je veux dire 137 000 demandes
d'asile sur le territoire français dont
deux tiers sont déboutés ne sont pas
expulsés vaste coup de fil et mondial
sur Web réseau clandestin sur
un prêt de 300 arrestations ont eu lieu
en Europe au Brésil ou encore aux
États-Unis pour parler des migrants de
Chen Viking que l'on a accueilli et qui
ont fugué dans la nature bref ça c'est
le bilan du ministre de l'Intérieur
aujourd'hui à force d'être banalisé elle
peut arriver au pouvoir alors que la
gauche dans l'état où elle est elle ne
le peut pas sur la ligne qu'elle conduit
vous parlez c'est pour ça que je pense
que nous sommes dans une crise politique
une émotion légitime et en train de
personnel c'est typique de l'extrême
droite j'ai détecté extrêmement bien sûr
l'extrême gauche et vous parler
d'extrêmement
excusez-moi je vais partir j'ai pas
l'habitude mais il y avait des gens dans
les cortèges certaines personnes sont
venues dans les cortèges du 1er mai non
pas pour manifester mais pour tuer des
policiers quand on jette un cocktail sur
un policier qui s'enflamme je ne vois
pas quel autre but on peut rechercher
évidemment qu'ils veulent tuer les
policiers ils veulent faire mal s'ils
peuvent les tuer ils le font évidemment
votre discours est insupportable en fait
ça fait une demi-heure que vous voulez
défendez en fait
j'ai pris des dispositions ils ont été
votées d'ailleurs pour que la réponse
pénale soit plus ferme chaque fois que
l'on s'en prend à un policier est-ce que
le RN pourrait soutenir une telle
initiative ecoutez ça pourrait être une
bonne idée si le contenu correspond à ce
que nous avons proposé avec Marine Le
Pen à la présidentielle notamment des
mesures qui permettent d'empêcher des
personnes identifiées par la police par
les services de l'ordre par les services
de sécurité comme dangereux comme
systématiquement dangereuse
préventive nombreuse lors des
manifestations contre la réforme des
retraites justement c'est ce qui ressort
du rapport de la contrôleuse générale
des prisons 80 % des manifestants
arrêtez le 23 mars dernier ont été
relâchés sans la moindre poursuite je
voudrais en profiter pour apporter tout
mon soutien aux forces de l'ordre qui
sont attaquées harcelés agressés en
permanence dans ces manifestations par
des personnes qui ne viennent pas pour
manifester mais qui viennent uniquement
pour casser ce qui est illégal cette
place c'est en garde à vue des gens
contre lesquels il n'existe aucune
suspicion d'avoir commis ou tenter de
commettre un délit ils ont rien sur eux
à la palpation pourquoi elles sont
retenus quand même
non ça c'est pas dans les clos et
l'autre passe ses compétences
digérailles Darmanin vous êtes d'accord
elle se mêle de ce qu'il la regarde pas
la contre le général des privations donc
je pense qu'il sait de quoi il parle il
nous faut
caractériser l'infraction suffisamment
la caractériser et quand elle est
insuffisamment payer un classement sans
suite mais ça ne veut absolument pas
dire que l'infraction n'a pas été
commise la justice est saisie
systématiquement c'est qu'on est dans
une démocratie qui fonctionne et s'il y
a des gens qui sont remis en liberté
c'est qu'on est dans une démocratie qui
fonctionne encore une fois j'invite
chacune et chacun à la modération face à
l'exceptionnel violence à laquelle on a
pu assister le crâne a-t-elle voulu
assassiné Vladimir Poutine à l'aide de
drones au-dessus du Kremlin la nuit
dernière c'est l'accusation portée par
Moscou cet après-midi dans un communiqué
nous n'avons pas attaqué Poutine Poutine
on le laisse au tribunaux ce n'est pas
une surprise une nouvelle fois à le
Conseil constitutionnel a rejeter cette
demande de référendum d'initiative à
partager le Conseil constitutionnel juge
que ne porte pas sur que cela ne porte
pas sur une réforme relative à la
politique sociale et encore
j'avais 20 ans je caressais le temps le
rip ne doit pas avoir pour objet
d'une disposition législative promulguée
depuis moins d'un an et ça c'est
magnifique un référendum sert
précisément à contrer une loi qui serait
adoptée mais contestée par le peuple les
Petits Hommes Gris ont tout prévu par ma
faute j'ai fait le vide autour de moi et
j'ai gâché ma vie et mes jeunes années
comment disons latin